[Music]
hey guys I just wanted to make a quick
video regarding the newly announced
Harry Potter ebooks on May 24th
Pottermore announced on their Twitter
that there would be four new Harry
Potter ebooks being released these books
are derived from the Harry Potter a
history of magic audiobook while they
aren't going to be following the lives
of Harry Ron and Hermione these short
bite-sized reads aim to delve further
into the traditional folklore and magic
of the Harry Potter universe each
covering a separate section of it these
books will allow you to absorb the
history of magic in a more digestible
and compact form the books are titled as
follows
Harry Potter a history of magic a
journey through charms and Defense
Against the Dark Arts a journey through
potions and herbology a journey through
divination and astronomy and a journey
through care of magical creatures in the
words of Potter more it seems part of
human nature to want to believe in the
unbelievable from the bestiaries and
cabinets of curiosities of the medieval
period onwards we think that truth and
meth are easily distinguished today but
magical creatures in the stories around
them continue to fascinate us and they
are essential to the Harry Potter
stories as Harry Hermione and Ron the
first two books surrounding charms and
defenses against the dark arts as well
as potions in herbology will be released
on June 27th the others should follow
shortly after I don't know about you
guys but I'll definitely be picking
these up that's all for this video and
remember help will always be given at
Hogwarts to those who deserve it
[Music]